j'ai mon exposé à faire en cas si tu
suis mon conseil tout ira bien mon père
dit que ça va bien se passer je
m'appelle angèle
mais je suis pas doué pour ça pas si mal
a été un désastre
et tout à coup alors que tout allait on
ne peut plus mal
j'ai développé un pouvoir spécial refait
mon lit et rangent leur est dommage que
ce qui se passe mais le pouvoir des
boues ses débuts un clic une grande
responsable qui ne devrait pas le faire
quelque chose avec cela tu fais quelque
chose andré tu demandes à ce que je sois
bon à cheval il paraît que tu peux faire
des voeux qui se réalise tu peux nous en
dire plus c'est super énervant de voir
toujours quelqu'un après toi q3 j'ai
surtout pas que ce soit moi qui décide
pour une fois charlie
j'aimerais avoir l'air aussi cool que ma
voiture et là bizarroïde à lui sinon
écoute amuse-toi bien mashaei mais
surtout fait attention à marcher
[Musique]
sur consoles que je me connais je vais
là où on a besoin de moi
[Musique]
mon père
ou pas
je savais de quoi coach paul williams
heures
[Musique]
bien très bien
tout va bien rien à signaler